danielle you show us what people really
don't want to hear right so this is
federal reserve data those cute little
green bars show who owns stocks in
america so the top 1 percent owns the
majority more than 15
of the stock market
yep and the bottom 50
you can barely see the green bar
so what does that tell you when you i
have my own thoughts by the way the
bottom green bar is the 401k they're
supposed to sell bottom fifty percent
they have they're living paycheck to
paycheck and and on the only thing
they're relying on is their house as
their okay the 50 to 90 percent there's
your middle income that's middle income
america right there they only have 10
percent of their holdings in stocks but
the vast majority of their wealth is in
their home
that blue bar and you've had the federal
reserve jacking up speculation
i i just this morning i was talking to a
gal who's whose home owner's insurance
is going up 40 percent this year here in
in in in florida i'm like what did you
say yeah
what did you say how much is your
insurance going to go up yeah so what is
the average
retired couple living on a fixed income
supposed to do even if they did the
30-year mortgage and paid it off before
they retired which that's kind of
retirement 101. what are they going to
do if on their fixed income their
property tax goes excuse me their
insurance goes at 40
i mean people are going to lose their
homes this is insanity so so but daniel
when we look at this so nine the top one
percent today makes what is it 465 is
that the number today is it
can you pull up the top one percent
income i think it's like 465 to 500 000
but they own the majority of stocks
they do
just yeah go to
top one percent earners top uh one
percent learners danielle there's one
thing that would top one position this
chart is not telling us what percentage
of americans do you think actually own
stocks that's not right that's not right
that the top one i thought that you're
you're that that's too low you're
thinking the top top
10 no no no i'm thinking so the one
percent the number i remember was 465 so
the top one percent represents about 1.3
million households who roughly make more
than 500k a year that's about right okay
500k a year what does the top 10 make
today put top 10 percent just add a zero
i want to say it's quarter million
because
i'm going to say less than that so top
10 percent only 15 15 of america makes
over 100 grand okay 15 top 10 percent
makes top 10 makes this is 2018.
so 158 and 20 percent makes six figures
when you roll the top 10 and which was
not on that chart when when you're
talking about the top 10 percent of
americans they own 89 of the stock
market
the top 10 percent
owns 89 percent go back to that
no it's not in the chart that that that
particular i still want to see the chart
i believe that i believe the fact that
the top ten percent owns go back one
more
there you go okay so the top 10 percent
okay so this whole concept this whole
concept let me ask the question and see
what you're going to say about this so
this whole concept where
they say the rich is getting richer and
the poor is getting poorer okay the rich
keeps getting richer the poor keeps
getting poor the rolex store sold out
the first day it was opened fully get it
fully get it but what i'm asking you is
how much of that has to do because the
rich
invest into the market the rich gets
higher returns on their money and the
poor spends habitually meaning there are
more spenders on the bottom than their
investors they have to spend i mean if
you look
okay look look at the flip side of it
the top one percent their net worth is
10 in real estate they don't care what's
happening with real estate prices they
don't care about the price but the price
of course the gallon of gases all of
this is irrelevant to their budgets
completely irrelevant
shouldn't be tied to the house you live
in
it you're correct yeah you're correct
but the bottom people all they're doing
is paying the rent and getting by that's
it they're living paycheck to paycheck
and we're watching credit card spending
i don't know if i buy that so let me
yesterday yesterday robert kiyosaki was
interviewing me and i said so he was
he's doing a
show there was like 30 000 people that
are going to be on this contract
the the lowest income earners in america
are going to spend 22 percent less
here's my point to you so he goes and he
says he goes and he says
when he was a kid he was working for the
rich dad who the rich that would say
i want you to go and collect rent from
all my renters from all these properties
that i own so robert's job was to go
knock on the doors
and collect checks so he'd go in
hey you know i'm collecting rent oh we
don't have the money you got to give us
another 15 days i said well you got a
big screen tv but you got everything
over here so it goes to the next place
and the next place and the next place
this is the part where i'm in the army
i'm 18 years old this guy named jeff
who's a good friend of mine jeff says to
me pat save 10 of your money i don't
save 10 of my money i buy jose coibo
jack daniels and i go straight to a club
called connections and i spent every
dime i was broke every two weeks i was
fully broke two and a half years later
when we ets the guys had the guys got
twenty thousand dollars on a bank he's
the same rank as me we live in the same
place he's got a nicer car everything
was nicer the guy had 20 25 000 on the
bank this is how much i came out of the
army with a mitsubishi eclipse twin
turbo
nice car but broke like you wouldn't
believe so for me
i think if we constantly just say you
know the the poor and middle income they
have to spend their money they have to
spend their money they have to spend
their money i don't know if i agree with
that
what you're describing is the middle
what you're describing are millennials
what you're describing is why one in
four
millennials still lives with their
parents because they're spending every
single time
on experience you're not describing the
lowest income earners the lowest income
earners part of the lowest are being
eaten alive by rental inflation oh i
don't i don't disagree with that when
you say lowest income you're talking
what less than 25 000 a year what are
you saying no it's it's closer to less
than 40 years 15. this particular cohort
spends 40 to 50 percent of their
after-tax income on housing
and the and the matter
after tax income on renting that's
important that should be 25 to 30
minutes 30 minutes but again the fed's
been out there jacking up home prices
with all that i'm not going to agree
with you there i'm not disagreeing with
you but here's look if if we constantly
okay there's two sides to the coin here
right one side of it is what one side of
it is you're right we keep printing
money keeps going up we're not
effect to buy buy this table but maybe
kim is when she goes shopping instead of
spending 360 she's spending 440 80 on
360 is what around 22
she's feeling the hike it's not six
point two percent this is it's like 22
percent but we keep making it but but
this is the part this is the part that's
the part that's the part i got for you
so for me
okay so when is the last time anybody
got up and talked about the fact that
hey let's start saving a little bit
better money let's let's change some of
our habits
let's actually start thinking long term
let's actually start thinking about
financial education wait there's a story
in here about you need the cuervo at 27
for a big leader i i don't know like i i
don't know with you because i think
there's a little bit of consumption in
there that you don't need twenty seven
dollars a big thing i was that in and
out burger with my friend i'm at in an
outbreak with my friend and we typically
would order lemonade and lemonade was
229 medium right and we sat there we
said listen we sat down with this one
guy says why are you guys even ordering
lemonade first of all when you put that
ice in there the whole thing is i said
lemonade is really 40 of it you're gonna
pay 229 for that's a waste of money how
many times you order this every day you
go to lunch we're like every day to
twice a day that's five bucks a day
you're wasting your damn money so here's
what we started doing he said this is
the trick or what you do he said and you
can save 200 bucks a month this is when
i'm making 36 grand a year i'm broke
he says go in
take a cup ask for a cup the plastic is
typically the see-through because it's
differentiation because they're taking
inventory the real cups he says take the
cup go get water it's free put ice take
sweetener take a lemon squeeze a lemon
in there that's free lemonade you just
save yourself 229 times oh yes
we did that for two years so we agree we
we're on the same page when it comes to
the
the financial illiteracy that often
hurts the lowest income earners but
right now if you add up what rent and
ass and gas
and essentials cost
they're they're negative they're net
negative because of what's happened to
inflation but you're also like i said
you're also describing millennials who
are still living at home with their
parents because they still get up every
day and go buy a seven dollar latte and
think that that's a normal way to budget
and it's asinine and they wonder why
they're in their parents basement still
well to pat's credit
the story you said that that you had you
were broke you were spending it on
cuervo but your buddy saved up 20 grand
you guys were making the exact same
amount of money yeah exact same money
this is what i said it's a nicer car
okay a nicer car that he took your f-150
he had a nice thing going on for himself
and how much money were you making at
this time
solve for inflation twelve hundred bucks
nine eleven hundred bucks okay so you're
making more money working eighty hours a
week i'm in the army i'm broke okay yeah
but you're making twenty grand a year in
the army whatever you don't have to pay
for your okay so listen some people that
don't understand is there's actually
formulas to this there's a reason that
your buddy was making the exact same
amount of you
uh was
you know had money and you were broke is
because there's something called a
budget or a game plan for your money
there's something called the 50 30 20
rule american blah blah blah there you
go enough insane the 50 30 20 rules 50
of your income should go to your needs
30 should go to your wants
20 should go to your financials savings
are paying off debt the problem is even
if rent is a little more expensive sure
a little 15 okay but even if it is more
expensive the wants start taking the
place of your savings or paying off debt
because if you don't have a lot of money
coming in or money a lot of money left
over you sure as hell want to get some
new clothes or you want to look good you
want to drive a nice car deloitte and
touch did a survey just a few weeks ago
they surveyed all americans and said
what are you going to spend this holiday
season the highest income earners said
you know we're going to take some really
nice vacations we're going to head out
of town we're going to the average
higher income earner is going to spend
15 1 5 15 more this holiday season the
lowest income earners in america are
going to spend 22 percent less this
holiday season
because their essentials cost so much
they can't buy what they want okay so if
inflation is here that's a byproduct of
bad policies it's a bipartisan really
bad policy the biden administration is
one million percent together delusional
about it we're one million percent
together so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]